[Musique]
sous le par à ne devait pas parler
aujourd'hui âgée de 20 ans elle chante
je suis élève sa rencontre à que sa
prestation devant une salle comble au
spectacle-bénéfice de l'académie des
arts trouve sa voie cet organisme offre
des ateliers artistiques à des jeunes
ayant une déficience au déficit de
l'attention ou un trouble du spectre de
l'autisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
familles qui ont des enfants tsa watts
ce soir tara est source d'espoir pour
marie-eve dont la fille est autiste
pourtant il y a dix sept ans
rien ne laissait présager que tara et sa
mère céline aurait pu recevoir un jour
un tel témoignage dès sa naissance
tara a des problèmes de santé elle dort
très peu et évite les contacts physiques
en grandissant elle a des comportements
préoccupant varona et demi à peu près
son regard était préparé le contact
visuel était très difficile pierre
faisait pas beaucoup de mots quand même
pour son âge elle est beau parent que
commencer c'est en quelque chose bizarre
je dirige est plus tous les autres sites
plus jeunes y sont allés des choses
comme ça à ce moment je m'étais dit ok
je pense que tara ah là là quelque chose
c'est que l'ap s'est peut-être l'autisme
s'enclenche un long processus
d'évaluation par des professionnels puis
le diagnostic tombe ça a été comme en
cette journée lorsque ce temps là
l'avenir de tara qui n'a que 3 ans est
sombre
les mots résonnent encore dans la tête
de benoît cultus que par opter jamais
qu'à voir te faire dit que d'épilepsie
plus tant qu' on le prend comme un comme
papa qui dit il faut que quelqu'un reste
de boules évoqué au corps et ce par
piqué et le ces petites le pur l'élève
puis c'est peut-être aurait fait que
j'avoue que ça a été dans ma tête
vraiment ok qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
les parents de tara doit faire le deuil
de l'enfant normale et affronter
l'inconnu le trouble du spectre de
l'autisme le tsa un vaste les symptômes
varient de léger à sévère il n'y a pas
de profil type
on dit que chaque autiste est unique
j'ai demandé à part anne expliqué dans
ses mots ce qu est un autiste
est quelqu'un qui est souvent dans sa
bulle puis c'est un trouble génétique
comme leurs enfants ont des besoins
spéciaux comme leur enfant est spécial
ils se doivent être un parent spéciale
des paroles d'autistes le au début tu es
comme un gps dans les impute patent dead
au québec le nombre d'enfants autistes
doblo quatre à cinq ans cette
progression rapide explique en partie
les délais de un an à deux ans et demi
pour obtenir un diagnostic dans le
réseau public
les délais retarde aussi l'accès aux
services ce qui pousse donc des parents
à se tourner vers le privé
alors moi je dis non et c'est le non
plus on y voit de suite j'avais un
travail au canada
non et ça paraît on constate des
différences importantes entre les
enfants soumis à une intervention
précoce et ceux qui ne le sont pas c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement québécois
depuis 2003 offre des services
d'intervention comportementale intensive
l'itie à tous les enfants de moins de 6
ans ayant un tsa
mais il y a un gros problème ce n'est
que la moitié des enfants
du québec qui on a diagnostiqué autiste
qui peuvent avoir accès à ces services
la fonte
mon argent faute d'intervenants le qui
peuvent appliquer cette intervention
doit être très frustrant pour les
parents très frustrant très stressant
aussi parce qu'on leur dit il faut
intervenir tôt heureusement les choses
pourraient changer
en mars dernier un plan d'action a été
déposée visant entre autres à réduire de
45% les listes d'attentes de lycée et ce
dans la prochaine année chez les bush
ans qui n'ont pas eu accès à ce
programme
tout a été mis en oeuvre pour stimuler
tara et la sortir de son monde qu'on
fait de leur côté papilles en fête
l'orthophonie ces données il faut c'est
y aller avec la personnalité du palan
les intérêts dus par an les intérêts de
l'enfant ses forces ses faiblesses et
c'est le but en fait c'est d'intervenir
sur toutes les sphères de développement
de l'enfant s'il n'y a pas de recette
miracle car accroît cependant que la
méthode des rats est-ce qu'il a le plus
aidé il s'agit de séances d'écouté de
musique modules et qui agirait
positivement sur le comportement les
interactions sociales et la capacité à
supporter les bruits
mais des écouteurs sur les oreilles
pilot il nous met différents sons il m'a
différentes chansons puis et c'est de
désensibiliser les fréquences auditifs
qui me dérange
ça m'a aidé à être plus sociales avec le
monde en ce qu on veut que j'ai entendu
dire
malgré les progrès les pleurs de bébé
sont toujours angoissant pour tara ce
qui limite les endroits où elle accepte
d'aller me motive mangeant pas sa fac
des fois j'ai le goût de pleurer je
stresse
je me suis pas bien si on me demandait
si je sais que ma fille soit n'est pas
autiste
la seule réponse que je devrai donner c
j'aurais voulu que ma fille n'est ce
propos this tu sais pas si je puis dire
ça je connais tu arabes comme al iman
puis c'est ça la changera pas parce
qu'on lendemain hockey auront
respectivement après des années
d'efforts la progression de tara est
immense à l'âge de 9 ans la petite fille
qui ne devait pas parler allait révéler
un don précieux
[Musique]
s'aperçoit en approchant le lay de la
porte que c'était tara qui chantait de
se jeter à terre complètement à tous les
foyers jonathan vraiment j'ai la larme à
l'oeil plus tôt du fait que je me dis
était pas censé parler
[Musique]
taro aso stéphane ménard avec pierre a
enregistré quatre albums pour amasser
des fonds pour l'autisme
elle n'a pas qu'une voix exceptionnelle
et larmes dont l'oreille absolue
ce phénomène est 100 fois plus observés
chez les autistes que dans la population
en général
ce que ça donne moi la note 4 temps une
pio quoi se disent ils ce qu'elle fait
mais c'est très très très très très très
difficile c'est pas même la plupart des
musiciens au poids c'est cette capacité
là d'avoir une oreille absolue comme
tara est encore perdu du moment où
est-ce qu'on s'inquiète quant à ramadi
j'ai dit est ce que tu as déjà pris des
cours avait jamais pris de court à ces
même pas c'est quoi ton et demi ton al
aucune des prix tara à d'autres forces
en vieillissant ses parents ont
découvert qu'elle avait une mémoire
phénoménale doublé d'un calendrier
perpétuel
je me suis amusé à tester ses limites le
15 juillet 2010 à 1 jeudi
c'est vrai instinct je dis je suis sans
mots tard à pois mais est ce que en plus
tu te rappelles ce jour là le 15 juillet
oh oui oh oui je peux très bien me
rappeler juste aller chez le dentiste à
saint jérôme à la fontaine c'est ça
chaque petit dos on s'accroche à ça
parce qu'on se dit est ce qu'elle va
faire quelque chose dans les vies tara
partait de très loin mais avec les
efforts soutenus de sa famille elle a
même obtenu son diplôme d'études
secondaires tu peux pas les magazines
avec ma fille sommet et qu'elles sont
hélas son balcon
condé jeter sa robe de bal c'est surtout
que c'était quelque chose d'inespéré
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait peu
avant et j'avais envie de croix dessus à
ce moment l'or mais les croix sur des
choses une chanson que que je fais avec
beaucoup de points
ce soir pour clore le spectacle bénéfice
de trouve pas vois tu arraches en plus
haut que moi en duo avec mario pelchat
[Applaudissements]
je toucherai
c'était énorme chanter avec moi je veux
je veux qu'on refasse sociaux à moi je
serais partant qu'on le fasse ou non si
je serais partant pour alors la
prochaine fois qu'ils ont offert un show
dans le coin je t'invite des petites des
grandes victoires c'est toujours une du
temps qui est tellement d'importance
parce que à chaque fois ça nous donne le
goût de continuer d'aller plus loin de
passer déry 1200 nous donne des tonnes d
ce pont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
si tu vas à